The way it's worked into my life,
curiosity and making movies and
television shows,
it's enabled me to be a better curator
of what's an original idea.
I think our first reflex is to go to the
Internet as opposed to seeking out new
people to meet because that's really a
disrupting your comfort zone.
I mean,
every time I do this,
um,
it's challenging.
It's just that isn't going to be your
natural reflex.
Your natural reflex is going to go to
google a subject,
Google the person,
oh,
yet I am Deb,
and that isn't how it's going to work.
But what you want to do is you want to
try to figure out how extraordinary
people become extraordinary.
Do I think kids normally just go to the
Internet and just stop there?
Probably because you are getting out of
your comfort zone.
Meeting a new person.
If you treat it as an act of generosity
that you are wanting to share part of
your life with somebody,
it will reduce your anxiety.
When you reach out to somebody,
you go beyond just asking you a
question.
You might give them a piece of
information.
Like when I've met some famous designers
like Vivienne Westwood,
I come to Vivienne Westwood immediately
with an olive branch.
I immediately say to Vivienne Westwood,
what do you think of this new
soundtrack?
Or what do you think of this piece of
music?
Because look,
designing it goes hand in hand with
music.
I mean,
you know,
music is going to be some compatibility
to fashion.
Ultimately what I'm trying to do is find
a way to intersect with how their psyche
it actually works.
So what I'm trying to do is understand
very quickly what is it that they are
going through emotionally because
emotionally what they're going through
is going to relate to what they do and
achieve professionally.
And what's deeper than that,
um,
is what do they think is their purpose
in life?
What is valuable to them?
I mean,
what has meaning in their life?
I made it probably the deep truth of,
of what we're trying to understand
within our solar system as human beings
and even as we try to get outside of our
solar system.
What is this all about?